all right k money
k money where'd you grow up where are
you from originally uh
i grew up in chicago chicago illinois
west side 290
austin area to be exact
west garfield park uh no no west garde
field austin area austin area
austin area only like i grew up
predominantly officer area i live in
australia to this day
in west carolina park is where i found
you though yeah yeah close you know
close to russia from far but yeah it's
he was in the middle yeah it was in the
middle tell me about your uh your family
um
well
my dad they both my mom and my dad
they grew up with they grew up with each
other they went to school with each
other um
ended up going up going out
having me you know uh my dating i'm
going to jail for about like six seven
years so i was without him for
probably like
most of the beginning of my uh my years
and stuff like that so i ain't really
know him like that so once he did come
around like i was really more with my
mom my mama didn't want me to whip with
him mama didn't want me around him and
stuff like that so i was like
i don't know like i could really say
like i knew him but i ain't know him
like but i got to know him more when i
was grown but i live mostly with my mom
like that's my backbone right though
how would you describe your childhood in
general um
um
a lesson
one reason i said it was a lesson
because
now
when i further my life it's like now i
know what to do what i expect for
certain stuff
so
i think differently on certain stuff
because the stuff i've been through like
family wise even
my sexuality so it's like
it's a lesson
any of us in your childhood um i would
say abuse
but
when i did
come out as
gay
it was abuse behind that after some fact
you don't want your daughter to be gay
when it wasn't no phase and that's what
people thought it was but no sexual
abuse in your childhood no not sexual
abuse like no sexual abuse ain't nobody
never
sexually touched me or nothing like that
like i feel like i was always around
the right or the right set of people
because my mama was scared of that
but no sexual abuse it was like i want
to see that sexual abuse because i know
how to go away about stuff like growing
people
they know how to manipulate their self
into certain situations so it's like
i always threw it past that
i feel like
stay in the child's place that's how i
feel like they kept me in a child's
place for certain reasons certain
reasons like that
because i heard about certain like my
mom my cousin got sexually less like i
was scattered as a kid
like i didn't want to see that like i
wouldn't know what to do as a kid trying
to get away from that and how to feel
after that so yeah
and you finished high school yeah i
finished high school i graduated from
north lawndale
in 2019
and then i further and went to
morton college just in berlin illinois
that's in berwick like
about 32nd and
central
went that for a year playing basketball
yeah i had dropped out
lost too many people
relationships with depressing
losing weight
like how a lot of not support like i had
no support when it came to like school
anything even though even though i had a
full ride to go there
it's just the support even if you felt
like that sounds like even if you have a
full pathway even if you have
a straight angle of where you're
supposed to be going it still end up
being a crack or end up being a turn
and that's how i had to realize that you
came back to the streets came back to
the streets the streets ain't going
never go nowhere
they ain't going nothing they always
open you up open your arms every time
no matter what
you're 20 how old are you now 21 21. i
just turned 21.
and and you're how do you survive now
seven drools selling drugs that's what
everyone's drunk
selling is getting by
because then hey it's
this is chicago this ain't the same like
i don't know how other cities is for
real but
this ain't for the week this ain't for
nobody that that's just now trying to
get into this like this is for people
that
that that that been through some [ __ ]
and that's trying to get get out some
[ __ ]
bro and i'm gonna use this and i'm get
out
selling drugs is is is something that
people do every day and in reality i see
it like this
just like i could sell a loaf of bread i
could sell some drugs it's all about
marketing
i was just studying business when i was
just in school it's like
i probably come off people will probably
look at you like yeah you probably dumb
but when you talk when i talk it's going
to show that i'm i got more to my brain
more to what i'm more to what i'm saying
more to what i go through
did your family grow up you were from
somewhat poor
i always say i was poor
i i felt like i was getting
a lot of what i wanted until
people felt that i was gay
people felt that i was messed with girls
like i have i had my way like i could
get anything i want but once my
sexuality came up
i won't get nothing for my daddy my
daddy didn't want to be around me
he ain't gonna look at me in my face
he told me i love you i could love you i
could leave from this as if you gonna be
gay
at
12 13 14 hearing that you want to kill
yourself you don't want to fall off you
don't want to do bad in school you don't
want to do that you want to go to the
streets and that's exactly what i did
went to the streets because that's the
only way people have to love me
what what else to do
i don't got nothing else it's your
family now that's my family even though
my mama steal my backbone even though
i'm i'm i kind of rekindled my
relationship with my daddy i still don't
talk to him like that
like i still keep grudges like
last year he forget he forgot to tell me
happy birthday i still keep [ __ ] like
that i can still keep that in the back
of my head because
stuff like that matter
i feel like certain [ __ ] matter but
especially when it comes from your
parents or anything that's that still
hurt you to accord when certain [ __ ]
don't go how it's supposed to go
so
yeah
and gangs are still in control of the
streets here in chicago yeah pretty much
gangs pretty much control their own
street like everybody got their own
group
everybody got their own scenery like
when you found me yet i was well
these we sayings over though we we
sayings we kmg ttg sayings mafias so on
the other side them foes
don't fold like we like we don't we
don't we don't coexist with each other
we we really in tool with each other but
we can keep it or keep it a level on you
some fact everybody trying to get some
money right now ain't nobody trying to
shoot at each other and do that right
now because if we if we wanted to we
could do that but everybody trying to
get some money ain't nobody trying to
lose their life right now
to a [ __ ] mad because the next
joint or the next the next block doing
more money making more money than the
next block
but
it is gonna get down to that situation
sooner or later because in fact it's the
people it's the people you bring it's
the company that you keep
like it's like it's always the company
that you keep that's why i say like when
especially when new people started to
come around they started to store stir
up certain stuff so it's like
where i'm from
is either b8
period
you gotta you gotta you gotta get down
to the needy greedy you can't let nobody
punk you can't let nobody play because
if you let one person play you everybody
else around you they're gonna look like
you like you a goofy they gonna look
like you like you
like you the bottom of my shoe i can
step on you anytime i want
ain't nobody gonna treat you
treat you like a human being
that's just that
am i gonna treat you like a human being
my friend will let you
be roughened up
they want you to be rough it though
ain't nobody finna be holding your hands
this car ain't nobody holding him where
i at why be it ain't nobody gonna be
holding your hands and doing nothing
when the police come they come ain't
nobody gonna be oh trying to no
it's just
it's just it's a superior point but i
don't like i don't know what much more
to say about especially about my
neighborhood like
i don't i don't really know how other
cities is but
i know how my city is chicago it's a
it's something else
the south side of chicago used to be
notorious for being the worst
neighborhood but i think the west side
where you're at
is probably the most dangerous now yeah
like even the
same exact block that you came on you
got documentaries from that block
everything like
that block ain't safe
but i still stand on it
because
i ain't i ain't safe like ain't no way
you go go you go be safer for real like
you got to make sure you cool no matter
what you can't you can't be worried
about
oh
if a [ __ ]
you can't like certain people worry
about this and that we were about
[ __ ] come and shoot we were
about somebody coming to shoot at us we
not worried about we're not really to
really worry about the police
like the police not even the top the top
problem right now we worry about the
next person the person that's just our
enemy yeah like
we treat the police just like we reach
we treat each other
that's how i see it like
if we if you if you if you're a cool
police we're gonna be cool with you
but if now when you starting to
think cocky
oh we gonna be all that cocky stuff back
with you
but police certain police they know how
to oper operate in uh in our
neighborhood that's that's why they have
to give us respect give us respect we
will give you respect if you don't give
us respect you ain't gonna get no
respect from us
like that's why they gotta understand
they gotta know the people around
and on these on these in these
neighborhoods because if you don't know
the people in these neighborhoods you're
not gonna know how to go about them
people come off
a certain type of way when they got a
higher authority you gotta come off
being friends being cordial you can't
come off aggressive with us because we
go come back full force anybody in
chicago know this
be cool if you come and visit her yes
but when you come on that and you go on
that wrong side
you go see how how chicago we is like
290 like
westside austin area is way different
than southside like they still do stuff
that we don't do we more to get money
and
getting a tool we we tell like we more
gunplay they're more into kidnapping
people still more into home invasions
and
and like stuff like that like we ain't
into all that like you guys uh just just
last week i think in the news there was
11 year olds yeah that's they they got
took they got carjacked while she was
still in the car 11 year old like we we
don't do stuff like that like we don't
be out there doing stuff like that like
we more into gunplay anytime you see
something that's going on our west is
either gun play
somebody get killed somebody gets shot
or something like that somebody getting
stabbed or something like that like you
ain't gonna really see nobody saying
somebody ran into some ran to somebody
house or or
or or somebody got kidnapped or like you
go see more of that stuff out south like
they into more that stuff like that like
they are different breed like we don't
see ourselves out west as the same
people out south because they think
different they move different out there
they gotta move differently i thought i
lived out there before like i lived out
there with a female before like so i
know the people out there they ain't
like out west people and i could
actually say they not
after some fact how they when they come
out here i got people that live outside
when they come out here they think they
look at us
and they think like how is they even
doing all this stuff they can't stand on
their blocks out south they can't hustle
and and and sell drugs ourselves how we
do our west they can't do that because
it's a whole different operation out
there it's a whole different task force
there's a whole different police
district out there they enforce stuff
different i think because of the
violence that they put on they sell in
early years so it's like we got i feel
like i was got more leeway but we got we
we more dangerous period
off the same fact the people that we got
behind
the people that we got to be had i was
like our south is still dangerous ain't
no ain't no doubt about that they still
dangerous they and they indicting them
though because it's like
they've been doing this for a long time
outside i've been doing this for a long
time i was really just got on to like
really really really really selling
drugs all any even if you think about
all our drugs ourselves
all our drugs is really coming from
ourselves
in reality because they've been doing it
like we had drugs out here we had
certain stuff out here but all that
stuff started ourselves all the drug
population all that stuff started i saw
we only had like little stuff we got we
mostly gang-banged out her it was mostly
gang banging on her mostly shooting at
her we weren't trying to get no money
for everybody was getting money off the
phone and want nobody stand on no joints
man everybody got joints now everybody
say we do we load now like the price is
low on we right now so it's like
everybody making money everybody trying
to make some money off drugs like it's
just it became a trend though
that's because certainly like we
certainly we got legal so it's like
and then leeway on we became even easier
like a couple of years ago we get caught
with a bag we going to the county
you get caught with one bag you going to
the county now you get caught with you
can't even get caught with a house
they if you get caught with an ounce or
if they see you with an ounce oh yeah
you're going to jail but anything less
than else you could have 26 grams on you
you go you go get away ain't no way that
was going on a couple of years ago so
it's i feel like it's easier now
for
criminals to be criminals and hustlers
to be hustlers that's how i see it
when you grow up did you see
uh any any role models and of things you
you could have done with your life i
feel like i don't have lawyers nurses
anything like that i feel like i have
certain role models in my family
definitely
because my mom was like she always
worked like she worked to i would give
i'll give him to that like she worked
her ass off to valk because it's for us
it's for us she never had nobody for
real she always made sure she was we
were straight
so it was for us it's me i'm the middle
child i had an older sister and i got 12
little brother and sister
so
she had to make a way for us
especially when my daddy
left me and left me how he did
so it's like
i wasn't getting stuff i i was getting
normal so i i went to the streets to go
get it i wanted those new pair of mics
that came out next week my mama wasn't
gonna be able to give it some give it to
me because she got she got to pay bills
she got a she got to put food on so she
get she bought me little shoes probably
three three pair of shoes a year
on the school year
but ain't nobody else doing nothing
ain't nobody else giving me none i don't
get money i don't get allowance i don't
get stuff like that i don't get special
privilege i walk to school i don't get
rats to school like people like people
don't get certain like like when it was
snow storms i was walking through snow
storms like certain stuff like that like
people don't get it
what are you afraid of
um
i don't know i don't feel like i'm
afraid of nothing
for real
i ain't no i'm not i'm really ready like
other reason i say i'm not afraid of
nothing because
the life i lived it made me not want to
be afraid not they made me want to go at
everything because at the end of the day
you gonna have to face that [ __ ]
regardless that's how i see it i gotta
go at it because i'm gonna have to face
it
either way either either way i'm gonna
have to face it
so it's like go at it
or or or
just procrastinate that's how i see if
you don't go at it you procrastinate you
you you stopping what's go happen in the
first place
you stop what's what's going to go on
anyways
so i feel like i'm not really scared of
nothing i used to be scared i used to be
scared to die i ain't scared to die no
more
just that's all just off the life i'm
living ain't scared to die
i live this for a reason
like this this this he the reason why i
lead this on bro i won't lie to you he'd
raise my litter like they killed him
my my everything went down like
depression
everything
so like
yeah
i ain't really i ain't scared of nothing
you have any regrets in your life
other thing i regret is the certain
relationships that i did have like
female-wise
i've been in two bad relationships with
that that to me down
when i was in college my first year of
college i had two relationships
they took me down i couldn't i didn't
finish college
where i finished my first year about i i
messed up in classes messed up my full
ride
did all that just i was in fact who i
was around who i was associating myself
with then it was deaths
that was saying no so it was like i'm
still trying to recover from deaths and
people down around me then i'm trying to
get support out of people that not
supported me so it's like
that tour my freshman year of college
down
i was excited
i was glad i had a full ride
i was glad somebody noticed me in
basketball
i was glad to play college basketball at
a high level
everything went down
it's like
support
families
relationships
life
stability like that's
that's a big that play a big part in
when you're trying to do something
they play a big part can't nobody do
nothing alone that's how i feel can't
nobody do nothing alone you need
somebody in your corner
have drugs been a part of your life oh
it's been a part of my life i always i i
always do drugs
always i try drugs
i do drugs i sell drugs
this there's always been a problem every
drill has been around my life
for my whole life
that's all i know you seem pretty clean
that's that's all i know what what what
drugs are you using
i i only smoke weed i only smoke weed
right now i was in fact i did all the
other drills before i already did a
decent mandrel i sold a decent amount of
drills i sold different drugs so it's
like
i can't do the certain stuff that i sell
because you ain't already made no money
off of s outselling and doing the same
drug that you sell i only smoke weed
right now
only because i was just sick like a
couple of weeks ago i i did just lose
weight i'm i am trying to get my weight
back i was in fact i was on drugs hard
like depression is real
like i see that every day is depression
what gets you the most yeah that's what
gets me the most anxiety depression
that that that put a hole in you that
make you wanna just sit smoke not eat
really
yeah like
i went from eating three meals a day to
eating once a day probably
like
that's how it that's what it pulled down
that's what that's it pulled you it pull
you every time do you think among
uh
for yourself and among your your friends
your age do you think
there's a
just a lack of opportunity for you guys
it is the streets and the gangs just
kind of like attract you
because mostly because you would think
meeting the game banger you would think
he's just the dumbest person why is he
y'all like some people ask me a lot of
people ask me why is you out here on
post bia i know this
i know this
ain't nobody it's the thing i know so i
know i know this or some fact i i won i
won just out here i was out here doing
this i won just out here selling drugs i
did have a way out
but
just like
most black communities most black people
that that's going on like this is what
will happen we don't have no support
this is what's gonna happen when you
don't have nobody in your corner this is
what will happen when when
your your sexuality defines you this is
what's gonna happen when when certain
people look at you a certain type of way
this is what will happen
you go have an opportunity a straight
path and you ain't gonna be able to go
through it because you got cuts and
turns
and and loops that you got to go through
before you get to that that end
it's always like that
it's always like that
everybody down around they could have
been something everybody from basketball
to football
to
anything they could have been a lot of
stuff anybody around me
what do you think keeps people down
most most things that keep people down
is the stuff that going on around them
it's either
you trying to be like the next person
or
you just don't have no type of financial
support you don't have nobody in your
ear that's pushing you that's doing this
that's telling you all no no no cause a
lot of a lot of these gang bangers right
now they not telling you they're not
telling a 14 year old boy to not to not
to not hustle they ain't telling that 14
year old boy to go to school a lot of
people not a lot of people putting these
putting these packs in these boys
putting these guns in these boys and
telling them do what they want because
this is that's that's already where they
hit it they just need a [ __ ] to
put that [ __ ] in their hands
so it's like when when that happens it's
like
[ __ ] [ __ ] trying to be a basketball
player forget trying to be a football
player i i'm getting money right now
that's all about that's that people want
to battle ladies shoot people want to
battle later designer that's that's only
people here that people want to be
famous we want to have money
but
people don't want to take the certain
routes the real legal routes to do it
the fast money the easy money the money
that you can get everything long-term
gratification yeah
that concept they want that is street
credit some some people care about
street credit some people care about
their names see
you only get your you only get a name
when you make a name for yourself
yo either if not that you just gonna
have your name your real name
everybody's gonna call you by your real
name if you don't have no like nickname
or something or somebody don't make you
a name
it's like you really out here no you
really are nobody out here
you really don't got nothing going for
yourself if you in the streets for real
now if you're not in the streets oh me
calling you your name is is okay
but you if you in the streets and you
don't have no certified name out here
ain't nobody gonna look at you
as a get a money getter they gonna look
at you as a goofy you don't got no money
you ain't know nothing you ain't gonna
kill nobody that's how they gonna look
at you
like i got i got a real name everybody
else gave me names
i go by k money i go bad i just got a
new name coochie man i
k mulan like k number now like certain
stuff like that like it's off what the
next person
what next person see you as
i got k money off me getting money
that's the only thing i was trying to do
is get money
that's the only thing i am trying to do
is get money now if for somebody trying
to get in my way of that hey
i don't want i don't know what i'm gonna
do but that's the only thing my man that
certain game bangers ain't like
too much into
really gang banging
they want to get money
why what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
in your 21 years
that
your world could crash down at any
moment
everything could be so good
but it could be that one moment
everything could just
it could feel like nothing nothing that
just happened
was even
even compelled to what just happened
like nothing that just happened five
minutes ago cappell like say if
i'm doing something that's so good i
just had a good game
but as soon as i just got that game i
get a call saying somebody died
that just made that good game i just had
that 30 point game i just had turned to
a nightmare i don't even give a [ __ ]
about that 30 point game that ain't even
my least concern i'm thinking about the
person that just died now
now i'm going to school the next day not
even keen that everybody happy that i
had a 30-point game i'm not even happy
now i had a 30-point game that's like
that's my least concern though i got
different concerns now now somebody dad
that that hurt my heart
so now
so now is tearing me down when i we're
really i should be lifted up
but certain stuff like that tell a
person down when when that's the only
thing that's around them
you can't you can't feel good when it's
bad happening
it's bad happening a lot down here it's
bad happen a lot
that's why i won't be happy too long
i don't try i'll be i i i
i make it look good i keep a smile on my
face but i won't be happy for too long
because i see the bad happening i see
the bad thing to happen
like
i don't
be trying to
get my hopes up
because you never know what might go
happen
you never know if it's gonna go down
people we could be all outside having
fun
somebody probably feel feel mad so they
don't want to come shoot
now yo whole now your whole day is
ruined often fact
you trying to be too happy that's how i
see it that's why i'm trying to be too
happy because anything could just tell
you down look at that in it i don't
wanna i don't like getting tore down
especially when i'm up
that's why i've been
separating myself from
the the
the bad
trying to separate myself from people
that ain't trying to elevate they sell
because you trying to elevate in chicago
you just trying to be in a standstill
again
you trying to be like everybody else
trying to just survive i ain't trying to
just survive you can't just survive in
in in chicago you gotta live because if
you don't live you ain't gonna survive
you go die you go something go happen
because you trying to move
more than
more than what's already coming around
you trying to move more than the
opportunity that's around you trying to
move outside the opportunity
you're trying to avoid the opportunity
when you opportunity to come take it
especially in chicago because it's not
the opportunities that's going to come
especially with housing
with jobs with anything take it
that's how i see it take it
all right okay money thank you so much
for sharing your story
thank you i wish you the best of luck
for me
all right thank you
you